and the Oscar goes to V Neil Steve
LaPorte and Robert short with
Beetlejuice
[Music]
[Applause]
we'd like to thank the members of The
Academy our producer Richard Hashimoto
our director Tim Burton Michael Keaton
for bringing that wild and wacky
character Beetlejuice to life our hair
stylist Yolanda to sing and a cast of
many other makeup artists Ed Enriquez
Margaret Becerra Mike Mills Frank
carasosa and many others
and thank you to the academy for the
great honor that we're receiving as well
as to Alan Monroe and especially to
Barbara solifka to uh for holding this
all together thank you very much you
[Music]